hey welcome to subnautica let's go
survival I never actually played this
game and I love these type of games we
played a lot of them on this channel for
some reason I just said bruh no more
video games and this game came out in
the middle jack told me this is like a
survival game but it's really a horror
game and you guys have a heavily
suggested that I play this game
so let's freakin do this new epic gaming
series let's go damn the game looks
legit did I just leave my spaceship oh
oh I did
hopefully my minecraft dog wasn't on
there I said that that's alright I will
find the new pet they're always out I
was eaten by the metal panel guys I'm
sorry
alright P I'll never mind oh no this is
bad what Renee's a boy
ooh I like the music I'm just kidding
alright alright fire extinguisher
spray spray shush shush shush just say
no to fire that's all you got to do all
right what are we guys this is my log
alright everything is as normal really
so this is what I can make seed
I love seeds what don't just say that
I'm sorry I have my best friend in the
world fire extinguisher okay these are
my different things I'm learning how to
play the game if you know this game
already good for you I don't I never
played did I put that in my inventory
all right let's go out see what the what
in the world is that whoa it's just you
and me mister fuel tank okay but it's
gonna be out there this is so pretty
oh wow it's just you and me literally
dude this game is so it's so pretty I
love it I feel like I'm just being
picking that but if that Christ ever
like it causes a tsunami or some [ __ ] I
already got my my slippers on nice okay
so I just want to make sure it's oh this
is my storage I got first aid okay
alright understand it what carry my
damaged
I used my repair salon you know okay so
we'll improve this as we go I assume
with like different stuff why don't we
just jump in right away cuz I'm gonna
see at toll today how you help or quit -
hey hey - this is amazing
what dial is that not up up I'm not
swimming with that day will have no stop
it
stop it ah man this is so pretty
mushrooms yes acid mushrooms table coral
what a dumb name I see I see master yeah
yeah yeah yeah block block look I don't
know why I need these but they look sexy
am i right
and the only one who's ever made that
joke yeah what is that
then neither flippy peepee can you have
like a flipper friend in this game what
is that oh my god there's many of them
hey hey hey hey alright I think there's
they're fine
we're fine Wow papyrus with this where
it's an epic joke this is so cool oh
they got a little baby ones
hey hey what Spadefish oh I got your
child what are you gonna do about it
don't resist stop resisting okay so I
don't have much oxygen as it is what do
I do with you let me catch you let me
catch you come on come on come on come
on yes nope another one yeah [ __ ] this
is awesome I love this I'm not going
near though it's there evil evil so this
I assume this is procedurally generated
so who knows like what we're gonna jump
into this is awesome
full of one there for the full of
exploration we finally get to play one
of these type of games as well that is
actually finished I just need to figure
out how to play the game see the cluster
quartz coral tube I can make bleach epic
oh okay here we go I can cook some
papers I'm not sure exactly what my
mission is but I will deposit my
butthole we don't have much storage at
all that's fine okay I think we need
some salt deposit if we're I'm gonna
live so look hey alright don't go near
me and I find salt deposits don't go
near me god I'm not gonna lie like
what all right Oh limestone yes yes yes
yes yes oh okay two scenarios really
scare me the ocean has always been scary
to me and and forests with a lot of wood
in it I guess it's a Swedish thing I
feel like it's a Swedish thing hey come
here
gotcha this actually have we fish in
Sweden block block
you just go up to stuff and say o'clock
that looks cool let me pluck you okay I
need these I really get am i heavier
oh god it's me and my best friend mr. I
me mister me music's where is this okay
alien egg I like it
let me pluck you let me pluck you are
you too big to pluck all right let's get
some I don't know if that's good or bad
I'm I'm gonna get on it I'm gonna get
I'm gonna go I want it to go anyway
really this is stressing me out there
it's so pretty though
look at the things Oh cuz the Sun is
setting damn it's so refreshing to play
a well made survival game so far at
least I'm a montoursville I think you
know yeah yeah lol this game is
disgusting alright back to the pod dude
look at this gorgeous kind of want to
play this in VR now they'll just make me
sick I know for a fact that I can make
lubricant yes
all right so we can make our first
little meal a little Spadefish Oh what
that's so cool and a pepper I'm sorry
man you're my only friend I don't know
why I'm making this I'm just doing it to
see what happens really lubricant you
never know when you need a lubricant
really and now I can make a fin what
okay so now we have new fins equipped
and has swing speed by 15% cool
I can consume this okay
delicious okay all right if I make more
batteries I can make a Power Cell what
do I want to make I don't know
I need bleach to disinfect the water I
need these and salt okay we're getting
there gamers I'm learning I'm learning I
don't know why I got so many other
things I'm just gonna keep oh god it's
so dark I have to use this that is not
what I wanted - god damn it
whoa I can't hold it okay cool
oh god this is terrifying oh my whoa I
don't need more but oh yeah what is this
silver core I can make a flashlight that
might be useful I should definitely make
a flashlight
what is this mobile god there's so much
to explore and I don't know how to play
don't hurt Swedish man in water we
explode
works every time they always fall for it
I don't know how they're so done
maybe I should swing more towards the
ship and see what I can find
oh god it's so scary though I don't
wanna go down I like it up near the
surface any let me further down and I
don't like knotch okay
titanium maybe in the caves it would
make sense if there's in the caves and
stuff I'm being a little greedy oh god
oh god I'm greedy I can't find out I
gotta die I'm gonna die are you serious
are you serious what happens if you die
do you die if he died in this game you
lose some belongings what I know I
didn't know our at least I know I know
the consequences all right
titanium we're gonna find it yeah yeah
no it's the party once it's Darth Vader
fish stop it stop it oh it's a boomerang
fish
I literally call it boomerang that looks
like it could be titanium what do you
think boomerang fish speak boomerang
fish all right yeah yeah this is
titanium got him mine quiet car they're
scary are there sharks in this game be
honest I don't want lice
yo what quiet Oh
Swayne boomerang oh god he's defending
that area oh my god come on boomerang
say something save something interesting
I need uranium is this uranium huh shut
up shut up I'm Swedish and I don't speak
Deutschland the food oh god oh god
they're farting stop it all right this
pod sucks dude why do I have so many
mushrooms all right we'll cook the
boomerang I'm sorry boomerang you'll
have to be eat then never ate the
boomerang before but today is the day oh
we can make glass okay
why does the ocean fart that makes no
sense this is titanium I did get
titanium okay cool so they're in the
caves I could have guessed that I
probably like yeah it definitely could
have guessed that oh they look like this
so there's different ores inside the
rocks got it I wish I knew that
there we go easy now easy another one
yeah I'll start with the o2 tank I think
I think that's a good yeah
breathing it's my thing now it's 30
seconds that's it
I'm not sure what survival knife huh wow
that's so cool okay we need a cave sulf
okay okay we just keep going gamers we
just keep going it's a whole new world
out there filled with adventure and one
there and wonderful and farting ugly
fishes oh yeah so I can read longer now
nice breath be like good joke so I
assume the more you play like the deeper
and deeper and deeper you can go inside
this mama god I don't like when it gets
dark though knuckle I not a fan
yeah ooh gold mine I mean quartz mine
but whatever you whoa what what is this
play look how much stuff don't get
greedy okay don't get greedy Felix okay
I'm getting greedy I got greedy I got
greedy it's alright I'll make it I'll
make it I'll make it I'll make it I'll
make it I'm like look at that oh my I'm
full of stuff damn it what do I do
I'll come back alright can I do have a
map I don't have a map
all right I'll just remember hundred
meters away there's an epic cave damn
look at the fish at night
did I call this spaceship of fish yes I
did be quiet brain so large okay we
actually have too much stuff now a
storage container would be excellent
survival knife yes I will shop I need
storage
I'll take storage I'm good at game I
just need a friend in here and I'm good
to stay here forever good thing I don't
remember where that epic aim was
it alright at least I can defend myself
now right thank you
what is that that's got to be worth
checking out don't come at me cuz I will
food don't you dare come should I murder
them I will murder you
I can't murder them I can't murder them
this is so unfair maybe I should just
scan them I can self scan that's a bit
self-loving
I'm just scanning you bro
all right cool all right so I have this
storage what did I just use does it
follow me oh it's not empty so I cannot
pick it up I'm sure I'm gonna get a
million comments from people telling me
I play the game wrong what I don't think
that's good I'm gonna go on a limb here
and say I think that's that's bad news
that's okay I'm not scared
I have a knife should i murder something
see what happens
oh maybe now I can shop stuff it's like
minecraft but not like really minecraft
you know what I mean yeah you know what
I mean
what are these Oh eggs yes what this you
dead you're dead that's what you is did
you just frickin exploded oh god I don't
really need better oxygen thing but I
can make better oxygen thing there she
blows
yes bet their oxygen thing Mahone earth
do i improve my storage this is
ridiculous I'm just gonna drop these I
don't know what they do and I don't know
what to buy bought balls what do I do
with this base pieces right solar panels
base attached air pump ladder wall
Locker that's what I should have made a
lot aquaria okay let's make a wall
Locker let's just do that I need
titanium whoa
pretty bye bye
yes I'm so hooked on this game dude I
think I'm close to beating it because
I've been playing for a while no I don't
like that all right I'll attack I'll
attack I'm not scared okay now I'm
scared I'm scared I'm scared I'm
definitely scared I'm definitely scared
cut with knife
I did something I did something guys
they will do gamer what what what oh no
oh my god I need to make a radiation
suit ok gamers I'm gonna save their that
was awesome epic smash like epic smash
like subscribe for more videos and I see
you guys tomorrow
you know what big peepees do they play
PewDiePie's pixel ings of course pixel
angst is a creature collecting game I'm
the primary shareholder over a bazillion
players have downloaded and it's got a
perfect score it's safe to say it's the
most popular game of all time
35 pixel aims it's awesome deal with it
bill with
[Music]